I've dyed my hair so many times black is
kind of what feels the most like me
weirdly
um even though like I think I'm I'm
naturally blonde I haven't had natural
hair color in a long time but I think
I'm naturally blonde it's much easier to
go out in the world and be a normal
person with a normal hair color for me
um it's kind of a life changer right
billy eilish gets real about her hair
Journey revealing why she's no longer
dyeing it wacky colors dude here's the
thing bro in a vlog for Vogue this
singer shows off her post performance
nighttime Beauty routine including a
hair treatment which inspires a little
talk about those locks my hair it has
randomly in my life been a thing that I
change a lot and I've had many many
different hair colors since I was like
10. I didn't even know that that was a
part of me like I just did it I like I
never thought oh hey I want hair to be
the thing that I do I mean I just think
it's like
if it's something you you feel just like
do that like and I don't know that
sounds like super basic but it literally
is Billy's biggest look is far from
basic she sported the signature neon
green huge hair for years but now she
explains why she decided to ditch that
die for a more subtle shade I've dyed my
hair so many times I dyed it blue first
when I was nine I think and then when I
was 13 I bleached for the first time I
got white and I had white hair for years
black is kind of what feels the most
like me weirdly
um even though like I think I'm I'm
naturally blonde I haven't had natural
hair color in a long time but I think
I'm naturally blonde it's much easier to
go out in the world and be a normal
person with a normal hair color for me
um it's kind of a life changer right
when I have green hair I couldn't do it
I couldn't go anywhere Billy's been
rocking black dresses lately and before
that she embraced a bleach blonde moment
after that incredible debut last April
she told fans she hit her hair makeover
because it took six weeks to take her
from black and green to Bright blonde
and in the middle of that six weeks the
2021 Grammys yeah Billy later confessed
to tricking her fans with a look-alike
wig on the red carpet covering up her
fair-haired transformation
[Music]
wig or not we're here for any of the
Grammy winners hairstyles keep the
beauty secrets coming Billy
foreign